sí pero caramba
nadie más de corazón que para darle
cuerpo vacilo queja
yo siempre decía que quería tener muchas
historias para contar cuando sea viejita
y de chicas me preguntaba cómo iba a
pasar eso si no me animaba a hacer algo
distinto a sentirme independiente era
adolescente y como la mayoría buscaba mi
individualidad yo sentía esa necesidad
de tener un acercamiento conmigo misma
verme desde otro ángulo en otro contexto
otra perspectiva yo soñaba con tener una
vida interesante porque no
extraordinaria
yo quería viajar a los 14 años estaba en
una clase en la escuela y le digo a una
amiga cuando termine la secundaria
quiero irme a vivir el exterior ella me
dijo 'yo también' y juntas pusimos
nuestros nombres en un papel y lo
sellamos como una promesa para el futuro
apenas termine la secundaria con una
mezcla de sentimientos y miedos que no
se imaginan pero muy fiel a mi idea me
mudé a eeuu pese a que la mayoría de las
personas me decían que iba a perder un
año de universidad que me iba a trazar
en mi carrera una carrera que yo aún no
había elegido yo no sentía la necesidad
de ir más rápido que nadie siempre había
preguntado por qué estaban todos están
ansiosos por su edad
trabajé y vivi durante un año con una
familia norteamericana aprendí a hablar
inglés fluido a mis amigos de todas
partes y de a poco comenzó a viajar para
mí se abrió un mundo nuevo un mundo de
oportunidades infinitas no solo a partir
de haber dejado argentina sino también
de haber tomado una decisión y haberlo
convertido en acción yo sentí que podía
tomar mi vida y hacerla propia a mi
medida que me podía reinventar como y
cuando quisiese
más allá de encontrarme en una cultura
nueva para mí se trataba de un viaje de
autodescubrimiento donde no existía un
día igual el otro imagínense levantarse
todos los días y preguntarse
que voy a aprender a quién voy a conocer
qué tan lejos puedo llegar y por sobre
todo de que me voy a sorprender al final
tomarme un año para mí no había matado a
nadie fue algo así como una inversión
personal que incluso hoy en día ya con
un título en la mano significó el
aprendizaje más importante de mi vida a
mis 29 años me encontraba persiguiendo
el atardecer en bicicleta con mis amigos
y armando castillos de arena en un
pueblito remoto australia ya maduro
a mis 30 convertir mi camioneta en mi
casa y hace más de 5000 kilómetros con
una amiga y nos dormimos no bajo cinco
estrellas pero si vas con un millón de
estrellas y nos despertábamos varios
días con el sonido de las olas todo eso
gratis
hace un tiempo atrás me fui a bali por
primera vez estuve solo 15 días un viaje
bastante turístico para mi gusto la
verdad es que cuando ya estaba a punto
de irme ya estaba sentada en el avión
fui me estaba yendo con tanta curiosidad
que dije algún día voy a volver sacarme
en la isla voy a hacer yoga y voy a
alquilar mi espacio de coworking
a veces creo que no me tomo tan en serio
todos los deseos que digo en voz alta
tres años después ahí estaba yo en mi
casa en baile con algunos de mis amigos
del color que
la verdad es que yo quería venir yo
quería ir a conocer la isla a trabajar
remoto hacer yoga no me imaginaba que me
iba a encontrar con una comunidad y eso
es lo lindo de estar despiertos de
moverse porque no importa dónde vayamos
la vamos a encontrar viajar en ese medio
que los conecta con otras formas de
vivir con los simples es una herramienta
que nos acerca a otras comunidades y nos
muestra que lo normal es una cuestión de
quien lo mire nos ayuda a aceptar lo
diferente y entender otros roles roles
que me llegue a replantear al observar
con curiosidad esta comunidad de mujeres
en birmania acarreando sus bidones de
agua en la cabeza lista para caminar
kilómetros y kilómetros bajo el sol
hasta llegar a su aldea o llevando
ladrillos en las calles de mumbai no
dejaba de sorprenderme verlas haciendo
tareas y trabajos que de donde yo vengo
no los hacen las mujeres hoy llega un
tercio de mi vida viviendo de una
mochila una mochila que me recuerda que
no necesito más que eso para sentirme
feliz que simboliza la experiencia
cuanto menos las cosas más historias y
anécdotas van a caber
la realidad es que no tengo casa propia
no tengo auto no vivo exactamente acá ni
siquiera tengo un cajón donde poner mis
cosas me tengo que despedir tantas veces
que creo que no podría hacerlo una vez
más
tengo muchas cosas provisorias pero las
historias las palabras y todas esas
imágenes capturadas con mi cámara
vinieron a quedarse para siempre una vez
alguien me dijo que estamos destinados a
expedir es la contracara de esta vida
nómada porque sentís que una partecita
tuya se queda en cada lugar es como
vivir una nostalgia constante y me hace
replantear porque elijo esto y me doy
cuenta que la curiosidad también tiene
su precio
comprendí que la vida extraordinaria se
encuentra en lo ordinario que esa
felicidad que te explota el pecho viene
de los detalles y simples detalles que
estamos muy ocupados muy apurados y
están muy cómodos para observarlos que
lo extraordinario también es sentir esa
esa energía positiva y querer
transmitirla de sentirse inspirados e
inspirar de tomar todas las
oportunidades incluso esas que les dan
mucho miedo
extraordinario también está en agradecer
agradecer siempre activamos ese chip
viajero en nuestra vida cotidiana no
esperemos a viajar porque no es un
requisito para ser feliz que cada
momento cuente y cada palabra dicha
también porque todo es ahora nada es
para después escucharte indistinto
rodéate de personas buenas sonreír y
sonreír siempre vivir la vida con la
mente abierta con los ojos abiertos y
deja que te lleve a lugares que jamás
imaginaste que existía yo te aseguro yo
te doy mi palabra que todas esas
decisiones difíciles esa nostalgia y
esas despedidas habrán valido la vida
ahora me pregunto qué historia quisieras
contar vos cuando seas viejito o viejita
muchas gracias
[Música]
una vez